and I'm delighted to be here it looks
like a great crowd I'm honored to be
invited to give this lecture I'm I'm
gonna talk about a lot of different
things I would know former mayor
Kishimoto is here and I guess she's also
an alum of the Stanford Business School
there you go
and I'm sure they're there many friends
in the audience it's great it's great to
be back I'm gonna try and do three
things I'm going to talk about the
nature of the world's water crisis
broadly and briefly I'm going to talk
about the concept of peak water and what
I and my colleagues at the Pacific
Institute mean by peak water why I think
it applies in today's world globally and
also in California and then I'm going to
talk a little bit about solutions to the
world's water crises again in the
context of the nature of our problems
and in the context of peak water to
begin with there's just not a whole lot
of water on the planet even though we
live on a water planet there's a vast
amount of water in the oceans that's the
big blue ball they're only a small
fraction of the world's water is
freshwater
that's the little blue ball there if you
rolled it all up and even that's a
little misleading of the world's
freshwater the vast majority of it is
locked up effectively out of reach of
human use in the ice caps of Greenland
and Antarctica in deep groundwater in
rivers in the far north that flow into
the Arctic that just for economic and
political and environmental reasons are
not is water that's not really
accessible to us the amount of fresh
water on the planet that's available to
us in a renewable sense is a very tiny
fraction of the world's water and even
that water is badly distributed in space
and time we don't get it where we want
it we don't get it when we want it there
are rich parts water rich parts of the
planet there water poor parts of the
planet if you think about California
that's sort of the situation in
California we get all of our water in
the winter months now from November
through April we get most of it in
Northern California and in the Sierra
Nevada and the demand is in Southern
California mostly and along the coasts
so there's again the space-time
discontinuity in the hydrologic cycle
and because of that we build
infrastructure we spend billions of
dollars in California and in the United
States and worldwide to capture water
when we get it and to move it from where
we get it to where we want it that's
what we've done here in the United
States it's what we've done in the
western United States we've built
massive dams that store water in the
winter months so we can use it in the in
the dry season we build massive
aqueducts so we can move it from
Northern California to Southern
California or just the Central Valley
where the big demand is that's the
nature of our water systems we have the
hydrologic system and we have the
systems that we humans build to manage
those water that hydrologic cycle so
when I say there's a world water crisis
what do I mean I'm going to go through
this pretty quickly but there's there
are a lot of components to this I do
believe there's a water crisis worldwide
I think it's manifest in different ways
in different places at different times
but the biggest problem I see is the
failure to meet basic human needs for
water we have failed as a global society
or as national governments or as local
communities we have failed to meet basic
human needs for everyone there are
perhaps a billion people worldwide
without access to safe drinking water
there are two and a half billion people
worldwide without access to adequate
sanitation services and that's what I
mean by the failure to meet basic human
needs for water we know how to provide
safe clean water we know how to provide
adequate sanitation but we fail to do it
for a very significant fraction of the
world's population and that's a crisis
all by itself that leads directly to
water related diseases cholera dysentery
guinea worm schistosomiasis a whole
series of things that are completely
preventable we know how to prevent water
related diseases but are not prevent
because we have failed to meet demands
for safe water and adequate sanitation
the estimate is that there are probably
one-and-a-half to two million deaths a
year from preventable water related
diseases mostly children mostly under
the age of five entirely in my opinion
preventable and that's a crisis most
people when they think about the water
crisis they think okay it's scarcity
it's there's just not enough water to do
the things we want to do and that's
certainly an important part of this
problem but we have local water scarcity
we have resource depletion and I'll come
back to this issue of depletion in a
little bit but there are parts of the
planet that are dry where there is not
enough water to do all of the things
humans might want to do if you think
about northern Africa you think about
the Persian Gulf you think about parts
of the western United States that are
just dry compared to other parts of the
world where there are resource
constraints and I would argue growing
resource constraints there's a water
quality component we contaminate a huge
amount of the fresh water that is in
theory available to us with human wastes
with industrial wastes they're naturally
occurring contaminants that make some
water resources unfit for certain kinds
of human uses such as the arsenic
problem in Bangladesh and West Bengal
India a natural naturally occurring
arsenic but it's arsenic that is
basically at a concentration too high
for most human uses so there all sorts
of pieces of water contamination that
are part of the world's water crisis and
ironically in many parts of the world
the water quantity problem is really in
fact a water quality problem parts of
China now they have sufficient water
quantity but much of that water is too
contaminated to use so they're very
strong connections between quality and
quantity climate change climate change
is a real problem we're already seeing
clear indications that humans are
changing the climate at rates far faster
than naturally occurring climate change
and among the many different kinds of
impacts of climate change will
impacts on the hydrologic cycle the
hydrologic cycle is evaporation the
formation of clouds condensation
precipitation runoff back into the
oceans evaporation again that's the
hydrologic cycle that's the climate
cycle as we change the climate we will
fundamentally change water availability
the timing of storms the intensity of
storms the quality of water in different
places at different times snowpack in
the Sierra Nevada is going to be
fundamentally affected by rising
temperatures there are a whole series of
very strong connections between climate
change and water availability and that's
something that water managers if I go
back to what I mentioned at the very
beginning climate change will affect the
natural hydrologic cycle but it will
also affect the systems that we've built
or that we may want to build to manage
water resources and both of those are
important challenges for the future we
use water for a lot of different things
primarily growing food 80% of the water
that's consumed by humans worldwide and
interestingly enough also in California
goes to grow food we use water to make
semiconductors to to make whatever we
want to do they're very strong
connections between goods and the
production of goods and services for
human use and demand for water as
populations grow as the economy grows as
challenges with quantity and quality
grow there are going to be increasing
there's going to be increasing
competition for water among all the
different ways we use water in
particular as the population of the
world continues to grow to 7 billion and
then 8 billion and then 9 billion and
then I don't know what we have to
increase food production already 40% of
the world's food production comes from
irrigated agriculture and so we're
looking to increase irrigated
productivity rainfall productivity
that's a water issue in many parts of
the world and I'll come back to that a
little bit later there's an ecosystem
component to this all of the water the
humans use come out of comes out of
naturally coasts
the California water problem the
sacramento-san Joaquin Delta political
disputes that we hear about in the
newspaper if you pay attention to
California water problems is in large
part part an ecosystem problem we take a
vast amount of the water that we use in
California out of the sacramento-san
Joaquin Delta we move it to Southern
California we move it to Central Valley
for agricultural productivity and we are
already causing ecosystem collapse the
fisheries are collapsing the wetlands
are disappearing part of the dispute
about allocations of water is a dispute
about ecosystems they are all see in the
former Soviet Union
form terminal Lake formerly fed by two
big rivers the AMA Darya and the seer
Daria completely diverted those rivers
are completely diverted for mostly
cotton production in now these six
nation dependent nations that used to
make up the former Soviet Union part of
the RLC watershed all 24 species of fish
found only in they RLC are now extinct
that is an ecosystem problem associated
with human use of water and of course
there are many many other examples and
then there's politics water and politics
are closely connected again think about
California but think globally there are
many rivers that cross borders political
borders of one form or another again we
don't think about this too much in the
United States we have very few political
we have very few international neighbors
if you will but the Colorado River which
is shared by seven states in the western
United States is also shared by Mexico a
lot of the water demand for California
is met by Colorado River water their
series of legal agreements compacts and
there's a treaty which we signed in 1944
with Mexico allocating some water to
Mexico water is an international issue
increasingly the Nile shared by 10
nations we think of the Nile is an
Egyptian River but there are nine
nations upstream of the Nile that would
like to have increased use of the Nile
we'd like to have a greater say over
management
the Nile and that makes Egypt very
nervous the Danube in Europe is shared
by 18 nations water in politics is a
very complicated mix and there are all
sorts of connections between water and
politics and conflict and that's a whole
separate talk alright I'm going to talk
about this concept of peak water in
three easy shapes that all of you are
familiar with let me describe the shapes
to begin with and then I'll come back
and talk about how the shapes of shapes
relate to peak water the first is the
classic exponential curve that all of
you are familiar with we see the
exponential curve every day we think
about it every day those of you who are
interested in economics are interested
in exponential growth this is what you
want your bank account to do I guess
this is what economists like to see the
gross national product of the United
States do I'm not sure why maybe an
economist could explain that to me but I
would also argue that this curve the
exponential curve is in many ways at the
root of all of our problems all of them
in one way or another it's good in
certain circumstances but exponential
growth has a tendency to get out of hand
and and that's a challenge so here's a
global population from 1000 AD to 2000
AD and it shows the classic exponential
curve dynamic that is slow increases
them and more and more increases as the
the compounding part of exponential
growth takes over and then in the 20th
century it really gets out of hand and
and it's part of our problem gross
national product of the United States
from 1900 to the Year 2005 or so showing
you know it mostly goes up goes up it
goes down every now and then for short
periods of time those are our recessions
or depressions but exponential growth
and in the economy of the United States
the concentration of carbon dioxide in
the atmosphere this is the climb
change problem again from 1000 ad to to
almost the president 2000 2005 showing
the increase in carbon dioxide
concentration in the atmosphere after
the industrial revolution begins I could
show this for methane I could show it
for other greenhouse gases this is the
climate problem the temperature curve of
the earth looks a lot like this over the
same period because carbon dioxide and
greenhouse gases drives temperature so
exponential growth that's one curve
here's another curve again you're all
familiar with it
exponential growth followed by a
leveling off and then a peaking of
something and then a decline we see this
with US oil production and in many ways
this curve the oil Kurt the oil
production curve in the United States
gave rise to the debate about peak oil
I'm going to talk about peak water
obviously the analogy was is with peak
oil I don't know how many of you have
studied the issue of peak oil but in the
in the 1960s in oil hydraulic petroleum
hydrologist and geologist a petroleum
geologist named emkin King Hubbard wrote
a paper discussing the concept of peak
oil in which he said any oil stock a
local field a national reserves and
ultimately global production has to
follow peak a peak oil curve discoveries
increase the amount of oil that we think
is available to us we start production
production grows exponentially costs go
up as production increases in demands on
the oil stock increase the stock
eventually becomes more and more
expensive and difficult to produce we
eventually run into a peak followed by a
decline in the 1960s Hubbard predicted
that US would experience peak oil in
1970 he wrote this remarkable paper say
it would occur in 1970 or 69 or 70 and
it actually occurred in 1970 Peak Oil in
the United States happened in 1970 and
as production has dropped in the United
States since then some resource
economists and optimists like to think
well we could we could increase US oil
production and
and and it would go back up again
exceeding previous Peaks
maybe I doubt it even so if that would
be temporary I think it would decline
again after that and the debate now
about peak oil is when is the global
production of oil going to peak now this
doesn't mean we're going to run out of
oil ever it just becomes more and more
difficult to get more and more expensive
to pump as the prices go up we look for
substitutes and production inevitably
declines and I'm I'll come back to that
again a little bit later
sometimes we see it for the Dow Jones
Industrial Average not natural curves
but economic curves this is 2002 to 2009
it's come back up again although maybe
not the last month or two harren catch
worldwide from 1950 to 2008 and Atlantic
cod 1950 to 2008 there all sorts of
research resource curves that follow
this kind of increasing production
followed by a peaking followed by a
decline fish populations are in theory
sustainable if you don't over fish them
but when you do over fish them
production has to draw populations drop
it becomes more difficult to find the
stock whether or not these curves will
will recover we don't know that's a
biological question it's you cannot a
question it's a political question about
fishing here's the third curve again
you're all familiar with it it's a
classic what we call a logistics curve
increasing exponential growth and demand
for something followed by a leveling off
and then a constant level you're able to
maintain something potentially
indefinitely a lot of Technology curves
follow this kind of dynamic the
penetration of telephones in the United
States somebody invents the telephone
they start to produce it everybody
decides they want one exponential growth
in demand for telephones and then
everybody's got one or two and it levels
off cell phones DVDs they all follow
this similar kind of technology
penetration curve now sometimes you get
a replacement and if this was landlines
only maybe would drop
but it would be replaced by cellphones
but this is a standard kind of
technology curve we see it for a lot of
different things I'm going to talk about
this curve later but this is total US
water withdrawals in the United States
for everything from 1900 to 2005 and it
shows exponential growth in water demand
followed by a peaking followed by a
little bit of a decline and then a
leveling off I'll come back to that but
all sorts of ecosystem carrying
capacities follow this kind of logistics
curve there dynamics ups and downs but
it's a it's a fairly standard curve lots
of things follow the logistic dynamic
alright so let me go back to this issue
of oil again I'll talk about oil and
water together similarities and
differences peak oil peak water and how
they relate and let me do it by talking
about some of the some selected
characteristics of oil and water first
about first the quantity oil is a finite
resource there's a certain amount of oil
on the planet and that's it it's limited
we're not making any more on a timescale
of interest to us
you know maybe over millennia millions
of years we can make more oil but but
it's a limited finite resource so of
course is water if you think about that
first slide there's just a certain
amount of water on the planet but
there's a lot of water on the planet
essentially from a human perspective an
unlimited amount of water on the planet
if we could figure out how to tap the
big stock of water that is the salt
water that at the moment is too salty
for us to drink it's too salty to used
to grow crops but there's a lot of water
available at a cost and economic cost so
renewable or non-renewable and I'll come
back to this again in a little more
detail but oil is a classic
non-renewable resource it's this stock
dynamic again there's a certain amount
of oil on the planet we're not making
anymore
and once we've used it up it's not
renewable water is in many ways the
classic renewable resource although
there are some non-renewable
characteristics of some kinds of water
which I'll talk about in a little more
in a second but it's mostly a renewable
resource transportability oil is worth a
lot of money it's it's a nice compact
resource with a lot of energy for a
small amount of volume and because it's
worth a lot of money we move it from one
place to another
we we reach peak oil in the United
States and production of oil in the
United States drops alright we'll ship
it from the Persian Gulf we can afford
to do that I did the calculation the
other day if you look up the total
volume of a super tanker and you fill
with oil at today's market price you
have something worth about 200 million
dollars an oil tanker filled with oil is
worth 200 million dollars it's a huge
amount of money and because of that you
know the amount of money you have to
spend to move the super tanker from
there to here is pretty negligible and
so we do we move it if you were to fill
that same super tanker with potable
water and if you were willing to pay at
the at the end point some city or some
industrial process the market price for
oil or the backstop price for
desalinating water which is sort of a
limit if you were willing to pay that
that super tanker would be worth about
five hundred thousand dollars
compared to two hundred million dollars
and for five hundred thousand dollars
takes a lot of money to build super
tankers and to operate them and to run
the diesel to move water and so we don't
fill super tankers with water and move
them around you know we'll build a putt
we'll build a pipeline we'll build an
aqueduct we'll move water a few hundred
miles maybe a few thousand miles if
they're mountains in the way you have to
add energy to pump it over the mountains
that that's really expensive too we
don't move water around because it's not
worth a lot of money with one exception
this stuff now I didn't put this here
but I'll use it as a prop the amount of
money we're willing to pay for bottled
water
is is a huge amount of money this you
know so is this a dollar two dollars
maybe three dollars to then if you're in
a hotel it's five dollars you know that
that's that's a lot of money when you
think that the math that you pay for the
same volume of water from the tap is a
thousandth of a cent
it's an it's it's a thousand times
different what you're willing to pay for
bottled water so we move bottled water
around for some reason it's economically
feasible to move bottled water from Fiji
to New York or from you know from France
to Los Angeles it's economically
feasible but that's a that's an unusual
situation which I'm not going to talk
much more about I will say a little plug
I've just written a book about bottled
water will be out in a couple of months
about the history of a bottled water
about why we drink it about the war on
tap water about bizarre bottled waters
that you can buy and the claims for the
minutes it's a fun book and I talked
about the energy implications of bottled
water but in general long distance
transport is not an option and
substitutability okay so for oil
there is nothing pretty much that we use
oil for that we couldn't do with
something else that we couldn't do with
solar power or we couldn't do with some
other liquid fuel made from from biomass
or from something more renewable so
there are plenty of substitutes for oil
even for liquid fuels which is the
difficult challenge but even for liquid
fuels there are no substitutes for water
for most things you can't grow food with
anything other than water so that's an
important characteristic as well all
right let me talk about this renewable
issue for a minute very simply the best
way to think about a non-renewable
resource is that it's stock limited the
amount of a non-renewable resource you
can use depends on the stock of that
resource the amount of oil it depends on
the cost of pumping and it depends on
technology all of those things but it's
top classic definition is non-renewable
resources our stock limited
and when you're out of them you're out
of them renewable resources the classic
definition is their flow limited the
amount of water that I use today from a
river has no effect whatsoever on the
amount of water that rivers going to
provide for me next year it's a
hydrologic cycle it's not affected by my
use there's a limit I can't use any more
than the natural flow provides my
ability to collect the flow I can use
all of the water in a river and think
about the Colorado River again we humans
use 100 percent of the Colorado River in
an average year we've given it all away
to cities to the seven states to Mexico
to cities to farms there's no in an
average year no flow reaches the Gulf of
Mexico for California the Colorado River
Delta it's a renewable resource we get
it again next year because storms come
in and rains in the Rockies and snows in
the Rockies and the watershed produces
water but it's limited by the total flow
solar energy huge amount of solar energy
strikes the earth the amount we use
today has no effect on what the sun's
going to produce tomorrow
and so it's limited by our ability to
collect it and sometimes those limits
are high that's one of the advantages of
renewable energy systems so renewable
and renewable resources are flow limited
interestingly what are exhibits
characteristics of both the Colorado
River is a renewable resource but there
are non-renewable stocks of water in
particular what we call fossil
groundwater groundwater that was laid
down over thousands or tens of thousands
of years and that we're using faster
than nature recharges it and that's just
like oil you pump it out levels drop it
gets more and more expensive to pump it
it's non-renewable so we have renewable
water resources we have non renewable
water resources and part of our problem
today in fact is that a substantial
amount of the water that we use to do
things that we want to do is
non-renewable water by some estimates
and we're not good at estimating these
things by some estimates twenty or
thirty years
much as 40% of the food that's grown
worldwide is grown with fossil
groundwater non-renewable groundwater
it's gonna get more expensive to pump
it's gonna be depleted that's a
challenge especially as populations
growing we have to grow more food with
the water that we have all right so let
me go back to this concept of peak water
and I'm gonna define three kinds of peak
water in the context of these curves
that I talked about first is peak
renewable water again Colorado River our
demand on the Colorado River is
populations in the West grew grew up
until the limits of the river and we now
use the total renewable supply of the
Colorado River
now there's variability we have wet
years we have dry years but within the
average we use the total renewable flow
of the Colorado and we build dams so the
one we have a wet year we can store
water extra water so we can peak
renewable water means you can use the
total flow limit of a renewable resource
we may not want to we may want to for
political purposes or economic purposes
we may not want to freakin for
ecological reasons I'll come back to
that in a minute but the question is we
know there are peak renewable limits but
how much can how much should we actually
use there's also peak non-renewable
water and again I described this already
but when we have non renewable water
resources like the Ogallala Aquifer
underlying the Great Plains in the
United States the Central Valley
aquifers that were over pumping in
California northern China parts of India
Libya is tapping non-renewable fossil
groundwater we can increase our demand
it's gonna reach a peak and then
production of something is going to
decline first water and then the things
we do with water and we've already seen
farmers in the Ogallala Aquifer in the
United States shift from irrigated
agriculture back to dryland farming
because they can no longer afford the
energy cost of pumping deeper and deeper
groundwater and we see this in India we
see it in China as well and that's peak
non-renewable water
now I wanted to find a third term that
my colleague mean appalling happen and I
called peak ecological water and we
wrote a paper on this it's available on
the Institute's website we're doing a
journal article now about this as well
so on the x axis we have the quantity of
water used moving from left to right
more water is used for whatever purposes
humans use water and on the y-axis we
have the value that that use of water
produces so from a purely economic point
of view the more water you use the more
economic value you get you can grow more
food with another gallon of water you
can make another semiconductor you can
do more things from an economic
perspective now this blue curve mean I
draw it as a straight line it may not be
it's certainly not a straight line it
depends on what you're doing but that's
the general idea the more you use the
more economic value you get but if we
think about ecological services as a
component of this the more water we use
as we move to the right on the WHA on
the x axis the less ecological value we
get fisheries start to suffer ecosystems
wetlands start to disappear you start to
see a decline in ecological value
produced by that water this is the
problem in the Central Valley we've
taken more and more water from the Delta
from our water systems renewable and
nonrenewable to do things to provide
water for our cities and our industries
and for agriculture and as we have done
that
the ecological value also formerly
provided by that same water starts to
decline fisheries start to go extinct
and so on what happens when these two
curves cross and let me redraw this
curve in a different way the x-axis is
the same thing it's a total amount of
water appropriated by humans and now the
y-axis is the total value the positive
economic value and the negative
ecological value produced by the use of
water we get this
perv at the very beginning the total
value the economic value is growing very
rapidly and the ecological damages is
negative but it may not be very negative
take a little bit of water out of
ecosystems it doesn't really matter
they're used to natural variability and
flow anyway and as we take more and more
water we reach a point at the peak where
the use of one more unit of water causes
more harm ecological harm and economic
value combined then it produces economic
benefit let me say that again you reach
a peak where the next gallon of water
you use causes more harm than it
provides benefit measured is a
combination of economic and ecological
value now I would be the first to
acknowledge that were really bad at
calculating the ecological value of
water Stanford's been a place where this
term ecosystem services has been
explored better than anywhere else
and Gretchen Daly is work in this area
and many other people's work in this
area has has tried to get the whole
field of economics to think about
ecological economics and the value of
ecosystem services we're bad at it it's
a hard thing to do economic systems are
bad at quantifying ecological value be
that as it may that just means we don't
really understand necessarily where this
peak is it doesn't mean the peak doesn't
exist I think it's very clear in fact
that the peak does exist for different
systems in different ways at different
times and that in many places were past
the point of peak ecological value we're
long past the point of peak ecological
value in places like the RLC unless you
don't value ecosystems I would argue
we're past the point of peak ecological
value in California and in the
sacramento-san joaquin delta that's the
idea of peak ecological water all right
so what does peak water mean it doesn't
mean we're gonna run out of water we're
never going to run out of water water is
a renewable resource mostly
where water is non-renewable we'll run
in to stop constraints and ultimately
those constraints are going to be
economic where water's renewable will
run into flow limits once you've used
the Colorado River you can't use anymore
once you've used the renewable resources
available to you you have to look
somewhere else if you want to use more
water and we're increasingly hitting or
in many places exceeding peak ecological
water limits all right let me talk about
solutions for a few minutes there are a
lot of solutions to water problems I'm
actually in the end an optimist I don't
know how much pain we're gonna have to
go through to get to these solutions but
in the end I think we have no choice but
to move to sustainable water management
than use what I call the soft path for
water and there are a lot of components
to it let me just go over them very
quickly but the first is we need to
develop new supply the traditional way
of dealing with water is develop new
supply build another dam on another
River capture more water drill another
aquifer another groundwater well in an
aquifer move water from out you know
you've used your renewable limits here
find the next most distant River and
build an aqueduct and move it
traditional approaches to supply I think
as I hope it's clear that we're running
increasingly into constraints on
traditional supply I think in the
western United States with very few
exceptions there there are no more dams
to be built that make economic and
political and ecological sense I don't
think there are aqua furs that we could
tap equalent economically effectively
anymore I think we're running into
traditional constraints on supply I
don't think that's true in many other
parts of the world in many other parts
of the world we need much more
traditional infrastructure there's
plenty of water but it's badly managed
we don't capture it we haven't built the
dams we haven't go
the distribution systems we need new
traditional infrastructure in many
places although I would argue that we
better build it to different standards
that we built it in the past when we
didn't think about ecological cost so we
didn't think about social and cultural
costs of building big dams we need to do
that but there are lots of things we can
do on a supply-side but we need to think
differently there are other kinds of
supply though in the western United
States let's think about treated
wastewater we have a huge quantity of
water that we collect use contaminate
throw away collect and treat as waste
water and then throw away again into the
ocean that stuff should be considered an
asset not a liability in an economic
sense let's use highly treated
wastewater for the things that it's
appropriate to use highly treated
wastewater for let's think about
desalination where it's economically and
environmentally appropriate let's tap
into what's a very high source high cost
source of water but it's pretty reliable
if you're willing to spend the money to
build it let's think about rainwater
harvesting let's think about all sorts
of smart use of groundwater and surface
water together to refill our aquifers in
wet seasons the the smartest new
reservoir in California is groundwater
aquifers that we've over pumped if we
can recharge them in wet years which is
what we do with surface storage if we
can recharge our groundwater aquifers
that's a smart source of new storage all
right lots of places we build water
infrastructure but it needs to be
maintained to a better standard than
we're maintaining it let's expand
infrastructure where we don't have it
let's maintain to a better level the
infrastructure we have in the United
States we have pretty high-quality tap
water it's one of the reasons why this
is this bottled water sort of a strange
thing but they're also places in the
United States where people don't like
their the taste of their tap water where
we have increasingly increasing concerns
about new contaminants we know how to
provide incredibly high quality cheap
tap water with existing technology but
maybe it needs an investment of new
infrastructure
in general we need to improve the
efficiency of water use in a place like
California where we're at the limits of
our water supply were not at the limits
of our efficiency everything that we do
in California we could do more
efficiently we could grow more food with
less water we could flush our toilets
and wash our clothes with less water we
could produce our semiconductors with
less water we could run our cooling
systems in our industry with less water
when we talk about efficiency and the
Pacific and since done a lot of work
quantifying urban and agricultural
efficiency we don't mean shorter showers
and brown lawns that's you know those
are things you do in an emergency we
mean improving efficiency doing the
things we want with less water and
there's enormous potential for that and
I'll come back to that again one more
time let's improve our standards for
water quality and let's enforce the
standards we have there's a lot that we
could do to make our water cleaner to
prevent contamination in the first place
and to clean up water after it's
contaminated when we have standards
let's enforce them part of our water
quality problems in the United States
isn't because we don't have water
quality laws it's because we've stopped
enforcing those standards let's enforce
them let's use economics water is an
economic good it's also a human right
but how do we balance the human right to
water in the economic good component of
water resources that's a challenge their
equity issues their pricing questions
their sub good subsidy versus bad
subsidy questions a lot of the problems
we have with water in the western United
States are the result of old subsidies
that encourage farmers to grow things
that are water intensive but because of
the subsidies make economic sense so of
course they grow them part of the
problem in California is so we don't
price water properly believe it or not
there are urban areas in California
where we don't meter water still and
we've almost nowhere in California do we
meet our agricultural water so it's
pretty hard to apply economics
to water that you don't measure or meter
so let's use proper pricing let's use
markets where it makes sense but let's
do it in an equitable way let's improve
and expand public participation in
decision-making about water the kinds of
choices we make about water let's fix
our water institutions I could talk
forever about that we have a lot of
different kinds of water institutions
but many of them were designed in the
19th and 20th century and I would argue
they're not necessarily the best
institutions for dealing with our 21st
century water problems so this is I said
I would come back to this this is this
graph I showed in the logistics curve
graph this is the gross national product
of the United States in the blue curve
in the red curve from 1900 to 2005 and
total water withdrawals in the United
States in the blue curve over the same
period so the beginning of the century
the demand for water grew exponentially
with population which isn't shown here
but it's the same as the red curve and
with our economy it was what water
managers are trained and engineers are
trained to assume and planners are
trained to assume population grows
exponentially our demand for our economy
grows exponentially our demand for
resources must grow exponentially and
sure enough for the first three quarters
of the century that's what happened
and then something weird happened in
1980 in around the 1980s we split those
curves apart and the demand for water
today in the United States for
everything is lower than it was in 1980
the demand for water for everything for
cooling power plants and growing food
and flushing our toilets and making
semiconductors everything it's less than
it was in 1980 and and the per capita
demand for water is much less than it
was in 1980 because populations
continued to grow exponentially we've
somehow managed to split apart the
curves so the assumption our populations
growing exponentially our demand for our
art you can economies growing
exponentially therefore our demand for
water must
also grow exponentially that assumption
is wrong in my opinion
and that assumption drives a lot of the
mismanagement of water so think for a
minute if that blue curve had continued
to follow the red curve think how much
more additional water we would have had
to find from groundwater systems from
surface water systems from expensive
desalination if we hadn't split those
curves apart it was it would have been
huge we couldn't have done it I think
without completely destroying ecosystems
without huge increases in the price of
water and goods and services so it's a
good thing that we split those curves
apart so I'd like to raise the question
in the United States or we pass the
point of peak renewable water now sure
we could tap more rivers to some degree
we could tap more groundwater in some
places but overall have we reached the
point of peak renewable water not total
peak water we're not tapping all of the
water but from an economic point of view
because that's part of this from an
ecological point of view that's part of
this are we actually likely to be in a
situation where that curve is may go up
a little more make it down as we improve
efficiency as we change the structure of
our economy but I'd like to think that
maybe we've reached peak water in the
United States not everywhere not every
region not every water district but
overall so yes there's a real water
crisis takes a lot of different forms in
different places different times we're
never going to run out of water water is
mostly a renewable resource but we are
past the point of peak water renewable
non-renewable and ecological water in
many places and in some places those
constraints are beginning to affect
agricultural production industrial
production and increasingly politics I
think there are lots of opportunities
for solutions I think there's lots of
innovation out there I think there also
there's all sorts of good news that
drove that
flat in the United States in terms of
improving efficiency and changing the
dynamics of our economy and our demand
for water in terms of restoring
ecosystems I think that's now a
fundamental part of the discussion but
in some places it's going to require new
thinking and new approaches in the end
truly sustainable water management in
use is going to require improved
efficiency it's gonna require smart
economics it's gonna require better
application of existing technology and
in some cases advanced technology for
monitoring and metering and irrigation
use and so on and better governance and
management you can't solve our water
problems without dealing with the
institutional challenges as well and so
our goal in the end is to go from this
kind of a curve to this kind of a curve
I think we can do it
I think we'll ultimately do it I just
don't know how much pain and suffering
we'll have to go through to get there
thank you very much
yes that's a great question I could have
talked I could have just put one slide
up and talked about this curve it's a
great curve there's a huge amount hidden
in this curve a large reason for the
leveling off of productivity is improved
efficiency we're making more steel with
less water
we're MIT we're going more food with
less water our toilets are 1.6 gallon
per flush toilets or 1.2 gallon per
flush toilets instead of 6 gallon per
flush well it's the efficiency issue
part of it is this change in the
structure of our economy we are moving
to more of a computer technology
communications service industry that
produces more dollars per unit water
we're a big agricultural exporter so
it's in fact not that we're in we
haven't made up what would have been the
difference with that with imports and
that's not going on we do import water
in the goods and services that we import
but we export more water than we import
in the United States because it's
dominated by agriculture it's a
combination of all of those things part
of the leveling off is agriculture
there's no more land really that we can
bring into irrigated agriculture I think
we've put our productivity we're
producing more food because we're doing
it with drip irrigation and sprinklers
rather than flood that's improved but it
is largely agricultural leveling off do
you think that'll be the case with water
so kind of put any efficiency and a lot
of the other solutions aside do you
think technology kind of will save the
day and if so like it will it be be
salad kind of what technologies are most
promising yeah the debate about peak oil
in my opinion the legitimate piece of
the debate about peak oil it's not if I
think that's a ridiculous debate it's
when and when depends on the price of
oil technology for getting oil
the cost of substitutes you know
eventually if the price of oil goes up
enough it's more expensive than doing
other things and and so in the end I
think it's just a question when we reach
peak oil and production will drop it
won't drop to zero it'll better it'll
drop for water it's more complicated
because of the renewable characteristics
because of the ecological component of
water without a doubt globally demand
for water is still growing and it needs
to grow because there are many parts of
the world where we're not using enough
water we need to grow more food we need
to meet basic human needs for water as
industries and economies grow the demand
for water for industrial use grows I
think there will be continued growth in
demand for water worldwide but the
population of the world is slowing the
growth in the population of the world is
slowing I think we will reach peak
population at some point 2050 2060 it'll
be 9 billion or 10 billion I don't know
what it'll be but if there's any good
news and in the bad news of the resource
environment world it's it's that and
that once we reach peak population and
knowing that we can improve efficiency
ultimately I think there's no choice but
the globe will reach peak water as well
it water will be more expensive that
demand for water will be higher some of
it'll be expensive desalinated water to
meet demands and regions that don't have
natural renewable fresh water I think
all of those are components but but I
think peak water is inevitable that's
about good news in the bad news you'd
make sure your first slide about how
most of the freshwater is locked up in
the ice so what are we doing about
capturing that we hear a lot about
global climate change causing the
Greenland ice sheets to raise sea levels
why it can't be capture that in fact one
of the big concerns in the hydrologic
community is how fast were melting these
large quantities of land-based
freshwater locked up in ice caps
Greenland ice melt seems to be
accelerating part of Antarctica is
accelerating but not all of it it's at
various part of the problem is that
stuff's really hard to capture it runs
off into the ocean really right away
it's expensive you know they talked in
the 70s about capturing icebergs and
telling them you know sure we could do
that but it's really expensive to do
that so I'm not we're not going to
capture large amounts of glacial melt
from Greenland Antarctica for freshwater
purposes it's going to runoff into the
oceans gonna get salty we maybe salen
ate it and will capture that way but
very tiny amounts of water compared to
the large volumes
I mean Greenland melts we're talking
about seven meters of sea level rise
seven meters of sea level rise
Antarctica melts we're talking about 20
meters of sea level rise that's that
we're not going to solve our water
problems that that way the management of
aquifers particularly in China and India
and also his subsidence a serious
problem where is that overall we manage
ground water almost everywhere badly in
California there is no ground water law
we there's no ground water management no
ground water law you drill a well you
can pump groundwater and we don't
measure groundwater withdrawals except
for a very few basins where there's been
enough political controversy over
allocation of water that they've
judicata them they've agreed in court to
allocate water resources and so we see
over pumping it's a classic tragedy the
comments and we see that in Indian we
see it in northern China where we over
pump groundwater for economic purposes
in India the problem is part because
electricity is provided to farmers for
free so the cost of they don't really
see the cost of pumping and so
groundwater levels are dropping whether
or not land subsides over groundwater
aquifers that are over pumped depends on
the geology parts of the Central Valley
you've seen enormous subsidence and
those aquifers can't be recharged other
parts of the Central Valley the
groundwater goes down but you could
recharge them and they recharge
naturally in really wet years and so
it's a that's partly a geology and man
the problem but as long as we're not
managing groundwater in a sustainable
way we're gonna run into non-renewable
Peak water in a lot of places we
actually wrote a paper at the Pacific
Institute on privatizing water called
the new economy of water that describes
a lot of the issues around that pros and
cons their pros and cons there are a lot
of definitions of privatization this is
one form of privatization another is
private companies come in and operate
water systems municipal water systems
that used to be public systems in the
United States about 15 percent of the US
population gets its water from private
water systems but eighty-five percent of
the u.s. population gets its water from
public water agencies that's just that's
for historical reasons the way we
developed our systems in England water
systems have been privatized Margaret
Thatcher
privatized water systems in the in the
70s the French have a mix of public and
private water systems that's a it's a
big question their pros and their cons
water is a public good it's an economic
good and balancing those is a difficult
thing in the paper we did we laid out a
series of principles for managing water
in a way to protect the public interest
aspect of water it's it's a great
question it's a big one and I could talk
about our furled for a long time but the
big fights in the water world are often
about privatization in one form another
you know Africa due to leakage and
evaporation no I think that's way too
high the big aqueducts are lined with
concrete they no longer no they didn't
all used to be lined but they're
increasingly lined to prevent seepage
losses they do you do lose some water to
evaporation but it's not a huge amount
the biggest evaporative loss is flood
irrigation a large fraction of the crops
in California are still flood irrigated
which means you open the gates and the
water spills out on the field and the
crop goes into soil moisture and the
crops of apple transpire but a lot of
that water is what we call unproductive
evaporative lawsuits evaporates and goes
back to the hydrologic cycle and that's
partly the reason we argue for a shift
in irrigation technology from flood
irrigation on those crops that can
permit it to precision sprinklers or
drip you lose less in unproductive
evaporation you lose less in seepage to
sinks that you can't recover water so
overall there is a lot of seepage and
evaporative loss from the system but
it's not all from the big aqueducts that
you see driving down the state route
five well you know we don't have markets
for water in many places people don't
pay a price for water in general in
where we do pay for water services the
price of water is going up
inflation-adjusted and it's going up in
part because a long time ago we weren't
covered covering full costs water was
subsidized it's still very heavily
subsidized for a lot of users but
increasingly less so and for that reason
the price of water is going up I pay
almost the full economic value of my
water at home I don't pay the ecological
damage because we haven't figured out
how to capture that but I pay the full
cost of providing building the system
paying for the fixed costs paying the
operation maintenance cost
painting the wastewater treatment costs
for my water agency that's increasingly
happening the industrial price of water
is going up and it's still a relatively
low cost of production in many
industries so industries are willing to
pay for it so I think I think the way we
think about the economics of water is
changing and we're moving toward proper
economics in pricing water yeah that's a
great question and I should have
mentioned it partly what happened in the
1980s was the Clean Water Act prior to
the Clean Water Act industries and
cities dumped water on treated mostly
and we had Lake Erie in the Cuyahoga
River caught fire in 69 and Lake Erie
was dying we you know we had problems
with water quality so we passed the
Clean Water Act and the Safe Drinking
Water Act and the Clean Water Act said
two industries thou shalt not dump
untreated law industrial wastes anymore
you have to start treating your wastes
and it turned out one of the cheapest
ways to meet the standards of the Clean
Water Act was not to collect your
wastewater and treat it but not to
produce it in the first place to become
more efficient to reduce the volume of
discharge so the steel industry could
have treated huge volumes of
contaminated water but they decided they
could produce steel with less water and
that was true in industries across the
United States and that's partly what
drove down the curve it's only a part of
it because a lot of it was agriculture a
lot of it was power plant cooling and
the build-out of systems I mean it's a
complicated curve that's why I said I
could have just talked about this one
curve but but it was part of the dynamic
I'm not hesitating miss there's no
answer to that I'm hesitating music it's
a tough question we manage water in a
lot of different ways water is a
national issue and it's all all often a
really local issue so my water is
managed by a local water district that's
figured out how to collect and treat and
deliver high quality water demand and
collect my wastewater and treat it and I
think my water agency and many water
urban water agencies in California are
pretty good they've figured out how to
improve efficiency they've figured out
how to recycle and reclaim and reuse
water they've figured out how to deal
with pricing largely at the federal
level there are 20 odd agencies that
deal with some aspect of water USAID has
international aid devoted to basic human
needs for water the Department of the
Interior manages water with the Bureau
of Reclamation the Department of
Agriculture isn't interested in water
and food production the the USGS does
water quality groundwater testing and
water use measurement the NOAA does
research on climate change of water
there there are there's a huge diversity
of institutions that manage water and I
think overall we're getting better at
thinking about the complex nature of
water there are success stories at all
levels where somebody's figured out how
to fix a water problem that we caused in
the 20th century with new technology or
new infrastructure or markets in
economics that there's lots of good news
out there so there are lots of examples
work the Institute's of about we're
about to release and go back to this
packings org is the Institute's website
all of our publications are available
for free for download there including
some Pro some papers on water use
efficiency and the urban and
agricultural sector some of those papers
have examples of success stories and
we're also about to release a new set of
studies on
the agricultural success stories in
California farmers that are doing
innovative things they're moving to
efficient technology or they're using
better soil moisture monitoring or
they're working with the irrigation
districts to restore ecosystems around
the margins of their farms so there's
lots of good news out there again a part
of my answer would be no one's doing it
all right but that but part of my answer
is there's all sorts of incredible
things going on out there
South Africa when they threw out the
apartheid government in the nine early
1990s had a chance to do what
unfortunately we're not going to have a
chance to do I think in California for
example and that is they threw out their
old water laws and they threw out their
old water rights which had been
developed under the apartheid regime
they rewrote their constitution
guaranteeing basic human needs for water
and basic ecosystems for water that's in
the South African Constitution and they
then said let's have a national
discussion about the rest of the water
we allocate water freako systems for
basic needs and humans for basic needs
let's argue them in a public way about
who gets the rest for the mining and the
agricultural use in the urban use
they've done some amazing things in
South Africa Australia's just coming out
of a horrible nine year drought and
they've been forced to do things in
terms of efficiency and water rights
allocations and pricing and rethinking
urban lawns and things like that that we
aren't doing in California you know
people scream that there's a crisis for
of water in California but not compared
to what's happened in Australia we're
not anywhere near as efficient as we
could be if we were really forced by
nature or other circumstances to rethink
the things we do so there are all sorts
of great examples from Australia
they're interesting examples in India of
read local watershed rainwater
harvesting to capture runoff and
recharge groundwater aquifers that have
been over pumped some of them are in the
movie flow which you and I talked about
earlier the movie thirst describes some
of these examples in different regions
there are all sorts of good stories out
there
yeah we do look at economics of water
options all the time partly it depends
the answer to question depends on which
problem you're trying to solve if it's
basic human needs for water you know
what you would do in a peri-urban area
that doesn't have infrastructure is
different than you what you might do in
a rural setting where there's access to
groundwater or contaminated surface
water what you might do in a rural
setting in sub-saharan Africa might be
different than what you would do in a
rural setting and the western United
States or in India so a lot of it
depends on the specific regional
characteristics hydrologic social
cultural characteristics of a place for
sanitation solving water related disease
problems is a combination of providing
basic sanitation which could be anything
from pit toilets to flush toilets I have
to say the flush toilet it's a great
invention we all love our flush toilets
but it's it's also a great way to
contaminate a lot of water really
quickly and so we then have to collect
it we have to treat you know anyway but
there all sorts of innovative sanitation
solutions that have been proven to
improve public health
enormous Lee now the Sanitation problem
is in is combined with a yet in the in
the world of water you have to talk
about water supply you have to talk
about sanitation you have to talk about
hygiene education together all of those
things combined or if you can't just do
one without doing the other but there
are lots of low-cost solutions out there
I don't think it's a problem of money I
guess is the answer we can solve our
water problems with technology in the
financial situation we have we just have
failed to do so thank